You're saying that in the DG do server they went after Pisco?
>> They do Pisco. Yeah. And the guy who who >> Did
that come from DG? >> Uh yes. My saying uh you know we
we shouldn't we shouldn't think we shouldn't think that he actually
had this on his computer to uh well he hasn't been charged with
anything that we're aware of so we should just trust him. Like
I said >> well I'm I'm operating from the assumption that
Destiny isn't a complete >> Yeah. See this is the thing
is like you have to sit here if you're a good person, right?
You have to sit here. Oh dooby's not. And maybe I'm not for even
watching this once I knew what it was, but it seems so it seems
like such that I had to sit here and pretend that I don't know
that this happened and that somebody aligned with Destiny is
not responsible for it, right? And then I had to listen to these
talk to and probably tell somebody around Pisco that it's like,
oh, it's like it's it's like Jer Queen's fault that this happened.
It's like, bro, that the guy who did this doxed a bunch of people
who are like anti- Destiny. The person, again, I'll say the person
who actually originated Hutch's docs is somebody who was in Dan's
server discussing doxing Hassan Piker's dad.
People have really made, I don't know, substantial statements
on this whole thing. The part where Lost and joined. Wait, Lost
joined? No way. I just I saw that guy talking about this stuff.
I would love to uh I would totally talk to that guy if he wanted
to come on. Give me a give me a time stamp. We got a time stamp
for that. Prime Kai. Prime Primai.
Prime Kai. See here. We got Prime Kai. Loss is Oh, hold on. Is
this Lost and Harrison though? Okay, let's go. This guy's getting
aggressive. >> That the account that posted Pisco's doc
is Dan on an alt account and that he was involved not just
>> Oh, why is Doobie talking about this >> that guy
doxing
of other people,
>> Oh. Uhoh.
Wait, wait, wait. This is uh >> difference between the
typical 15-year-old and 19. >> And the reason and the reason
that there is such a >> that was some uh crazy [__]
that just got said and now listen, now you have my now you have
my attention. Okay, now this panel suddenly has my attention.
Okay, like no, I can I can correct some of the the talk around
here. Okay, we'll we'll go. We listen that came through. We'll
have to talk about it now. All right. So, I'll I'll talk about
it a little bit. We'll hit play. >> Is that
I dragged it back about 5 10 minutes. Okay. I'm going to go get
a little more food and we're going to watch this. >> Is
has has not been in the body or mind of a like they're still
developing number one. But even still, they're like you can't
look at it as 15 years of experience versus 19 years of experience.
You have to look at it as a 15-year-old hasn't had um the hasn't
embodied a body that is predominantly or mostly developed for
like more than like 6 months at best, if they're even at that
stage, what they usually aren't. And they haven't had any adult-like
experiences at all. Whereas a 19-year-old has been out in the
world having adult-like experiences. They've they're they're
going and renting things. Maybe they're in college. Maybe they've
been to bars. If they're doing the 1915 quote, like unironically,
like actually unironically, they're going to do the 1915 quote.
Are we serious right now? Are we real? Is this real? Hello. >> The
difference in development and experience between a 15-year-old
and 19-year-old is vastly different than a 19-year-old and a
23-year-old.
And the reason behind this is because the 15-year-old has essentially
no experiences and the 19-year-old has minimal experiences. So,
um I want to uh I'll let in because we still wanted to uh say
stuff, but >> Okay, hold on before we get into this. We
got a Mantis tweet. We got a Mantis tweet that actually kind
of goes crazy because she doesn't understand that we all knew
this. So, before I pull it up even, I'm going to say she doesn't
understand we all knew this. Let's check it out. It is um how
mad will the haters be when this drama blows over and people
still prefer Destiny to them? Not even CP can do it. smells like
victory.
No, we literally all thought this about you already. We all knew
that you guys wouldn't care what Destiny did no matter what.
We all knew that child wouldn't be the line. We all knew that
you'd be totally cool with this guy being a like literally everybody.
You you literally just said something. You're like, "Huh, they
they think that we'd leave even if he's a Nope. None of us think
that. We all know you're disgusting freaks. We've all thought
you were disgusting freaks for a long time.
You're not shocking me with this statement. We all know you're
a disgusting freak. We all know you you revel in being disgusting
freaks.
You You've just said something that totally confirms everything
I already thought. Thank you. Nothing's changed. Goodbye. This
is This is a crazy thing to tweet like, "Huh? They thought child
would make me go away." Nope. No. None of us thought that. Crazy.
Crazy to just like self- emilate like that on Twitter. >> Just
quickly, uh >> I just got here. Before I go back, did we
cover uh Destiny crashing out over Ethan today? No, we haven't
covered that at all, but uh we will be covering it eventually,
Matt. Yeah, we'll be covering it eventually. I actually, frankly,
totally forgot about it, but we're gonna watch this guy, this
caller, real quick, and then we'll uh I think we'll get to that.
>> Um chat from uh Mcdevin $2 says Taylor Swift dated Shark
Boy uh when he was 17.
>> good for him. >> She was 19 Chad. >> She
was 19. She was I don't give a about >> Yeah. Um and uh
and I'll say just one thing quickly on what uh Scott said. I
think adult situation >> Lawson please like >> if
we want to say well look you know there not you know both 15year-olds
and 19 year olds like they're really just kids when you think
about it right both of them they're pretty dumb. They're you
know you know airheads.
>> Yeah we have lines. >> Are you serious?
We we got to draw a line somewhere, right? Because I also I sure
which we have, right? >> But like
so so
do you think there's Okay, there's a legal obviously a legal
difference at 18. Do you think there's like a moral
between 15 and and 19.
>> Yeah, probably.
>> All right. Well, there you go. >> It's not a black
and white. Like I I don't we don't need to have the age of consent
conversation, but like no one no one here is going to say with
a serious straight face that like >> the 17 >> Come
on, guys. You're not going to have the age of consent. Conor
made a whole chart. Conor made an entire chart and they're not
even going to they're not even going to have the conversation.
>> A week before their birthday is substantially different
than like an 18-year-old a week after their birthday. So, let's
just not pretend and just say >> a 36-year-old shouldn't
be trying to either of them. >> Should fine, but one is
legal and one is illegal. There there actually is a little bit
of >> That's why I say I don't give a [__]
about legality, Connor. One being legal doesn't mean it's okay.
>> There is
I I can work with this if we want to not care about legality
for the rest of this conversation. I'm all down with that.
>> Concerned, I'm sure. >> But I know someone's going
to pull out legality when it suits them. So >> both are
wrong. >> Like what the it's wrong on two accounts. I I
think that I think that when you introduce legality, like that
does affect the morality to some extent because what somebody
can do legally, it like affects their like like >> their
capacity, right? So if you're an 18-y old, >> bit of a
red flag, right? >> Well, no, hold on. No, not actually.
I mean capacity in terms of like quite literally what they can
do, right? So if you think the law is just codified group morality,
which most people do, right? Your group, your your country, your
like locality, they usually have some idea of what's right and
wrong. And the things that are really wrong are usually illegal
to some extent. If you believe that, then constantly cutting
against the group codified morality is probably indicative of
some asocial like antisocial tendency, right? Like that seems
like a pretty easy uh I don't know if it's the same guy Jakun.
I thought it was, but maybe you're an 18-year-old, you can own
property, you know, you can own property, you can uh you know,
yeah, you can you can vote. >> You can die for your country.
>> You can Yes, you can die for your country. You can do
all these things, right? Like you have the capacity now to do
all these things. While a 17-year-old, they can't own property,
right? They can't vote. They don't have participation in our
society to the extent that their birthday is a month away. Even
if their birthday is a month away. Exactly. >> Sure. Okay.
Fair enough. Um I do um you've been waiting. I do then lost.
>> Yeah. So Lawson, I mean I asked you to be coming here
because you said that uh you know these stories blow up, people
make money and then when we find out that it's not that Destiny
is evil or did something wrong or whatever, nobody cares about
it. But I don't think this is a case of that, right? So like
from my perspective, this is very obviously he did a really stupid
thing and continues to do stupid things and throughout this whole
process which specifically we need to be specific here. We can't
do the I don't want to do the broad like this is a pattern and
blah blah blah like cuz it's just Yeah. >> So So the thing
I'm talking about is not it's just not a thing. Can we not do
the nuh-uh and yhu like it's just it's so stupid and boring.
>> So the thing I'm currently talking about is the holding
on to the uh potential I think it is like cam um for like 8 n
10 months after he was told that the girl was 17 years old. >> Like
I think that's ridiculous obviously. So >> okay and I assume
I assume what you're saying comes from um like the Willie Mac
that you posted. >> No not just that. So, I was saying
this earlier, right? So, when I looked at this girl, like I said,
like last August, right, to figure out who the [__]
this person was and I did see that she said she was 18 in her
bio, right? So, when they said that this girl had been found,
I looked at Kiwi Farms and I'm not a Kiwi Farm person to be clear,
but I did look at Kiwi Farms to see if this was actually the
same person that I saw cuz some people were saying it wasn't
her. I think our relevant said it was like a twin. I don't know
why the [__] would make any difference.
Twin, >> Dubie just throws out. Doobie's like uh not actually
watching all that much. He just throws out of nowhere. >> Yeah,
they're the same age. Okay. Um >> twins, but they she just
dated for another sex. Yeah, like stupid. Like, yeah. So, I looked
it up, right? See, this is the same person I saw. And it is the
same person I saw. This is not This is absolutely her. And all
the other they found where they found her birthday. Uh they from
like a like a traffic ticket, some other >> Yeah. They
found like like a bunch of where she like bliss, right? And >> there's
another piece of documentary evidence that kind of that like
this person, the person who got docked, that is 100% a girl who
was who was a minor when Rose was having this conversation with
Destiny. Okay. >> It see Yeah. Seems very clear. Yeah.
At the time, she was 17 years old. >> So, yeah. Okay. But
I'm talking about like the the evidence or whatever that Destiny
has CP on his computer. >> Oh yeah, he Yeah, he
>> uh in the DMs with the Will guy. He said >> that's
what that's what I just said, bro. Like that's what I'm trying
to get to. So I assuming the the Yeah, the specific message you're
talking about is um yes, I created copies of all our messages
and everything when that court case started. >> Is that
really ask him if he has it and he says yes. >> He takes
a picture of
it on his >> So here's my question. Um why would Destiny
ever admit this to Willie Mac knowing who Willie Mac is? He's
an idiot. Why would he do the other [__] he >> Um,
my argument is actually Destiny's like smart and do you think
he could be as big a political debater if he wasn't smart? And
would a smart people would a smart person do this? Would a smart
person do this? Really? >> Actually, this reminds me of
something that I want to get caught. >> Hold on. I want
to get you. Wait, do you actually believe that? >> So,
so this is like a common uh tactic, right, of like manipulative
people that Destiny himself laid out once. I remember seeing
and I was like, "Oh, yeah, that is the thing manipulative people
do. It's like when you get caught doing a really stupid thing
and if the other person knows you and they think they think you're
an intelligent person, but you did do the really [__]
stupid thing, you're if you say, "Hey, do do you really think
I would do something like that? Do you really think I would do
something that's stupid?" >> But he wasn't caught at all.
>> And that's enough. That's enough to gaslight people
into thinking, "Oh, no, maybe he didn't actually do this stupid
thing that he wouldn't." >> This is This guy's about to
say something. He obviously traded videos with Rose. That's obviously
in the logs to begin with, right? Him soliciting videos from
her. Um, and then once you find out she's 17, you know that he
solicited videos from her. It's just a matter of whether or not
he still has the files, whether or not he went to the cops. But
like the fact that he had seam at some point was already known
before that Willy M call. He's too smart to do that. But but
again and again, Destiny's been talking really fast. >> Not
the general thing. Stay on stay on one thing. I'm >> talking
about this one thing. >> No, but you're saying again and
again in all the Willy Mac that he had this on his computer.
He did. >> Why are you Why do you keep trying to frame
people's arguments and what arguments they're allowed to make?
Who is this
>> So before he said, "Yes, I created copies of all our
messages and everything." What was the proof that like Destiny
had it on his computer? Uh >> the video title, right? And
and hold on. Prior to the video title. >> Yeah. The uh
name of the file. Hold on. prior to this um >> a VLC media
player that had the title that he said was the title of the file
that had the cam. So he had to have seen the metadata for the
file or the file name had to be shown to him and he had to see
that if he has a screen of Rose sending him that clip of the
of the VC media player then maybe he can make that argument.
But why wouldn't he have just produced that? >> I think
this was before the Mac video. People were saying that um and
I don't mean just randomized people. people that are associated
with Destiny and Dan and have been in their little circles and
we're able to prove that they were in a >> I need I can't
deal with I can't like >> that's fine I can show you I
can show you later if he's not aware but I can just tell you
right now >> can you show me now >> I'd have to pull
it I have to dig it up for you right so I I have been following
this the story right um and I've been aware of these things so
people that were in these circles these doxing circles that that
Danny Desmond put together um said that circles >> noxing
no doxing don't do that
actively >> counterdoxing servers counterdoxing servers
let's not pay any attention to the fact that they do Sunday and
Hassan's editor in like the same month let's not do It's not
doxing, bro. It's counterd doxing. >> Who do pisco dox?
>> Who do pisco dox? >> I don't think he docks anybody.
>> Yeah, they dox Bisco and and the guy that Hold on. One
of the guys involved said that Dan was one that on the account
that that did it that posted it.
>> Correct. I need to >> Okay, what do you mean counter
doxing? Like, what do you mean? >> Hold on, dude. I need
to I need to hear this real quick. You're saying that in the
DG Counterdoc server, they went after Pisco >> on Kiwi
Farms. They doxed Pisco. Yeah. And the guy who >> Did that
come from DG? >> Uh, yes. My understanding is the guy who
said that the guy the guy who >> Yeah. See, this is the
thing is like you have to sit here if you're a good person, right?
You have to sit here. Oh, doob. He's not. And maybe I'm not for
even watching this once I knew what it was. But it seems so it
seems like such
that I had to sit here and pretend that I don't know that this
happened and that somebody aligned with Destiny is not responsible
for it, right? And then I had to listen to these talk to and
probably tell somebody around Pisco that it's like, "Oh, it's
like it's it's like Jer Queen's fault that this happened." It's
like, bro, that the guy who did this doxed a bunch of people
who are like anti- destiny. It's such it's
the counterdoxing that is actually just aggressive doxing, right?
Like they're the doxers. Uh he said that that the account that
posted Pisco Doc is Dan on an alt account and he was involved
not just ducks in that guy, but doxing a ton of other people,
right?
Yes. And in the server, um uh they were posting Destiny was posting
images, but also themselves of this girl when she was underage
to try to so they could take images from it and try to find her.
and they had to tell him to blur out her [__] titles
because she might be underage. So, this was recent. So, obviously
he still has has access to them in some >> Okay, so Okay,
I'm trying not to ping pong between the docks and and the the
having CP on his computer. >> Sure, that's fine. You can
focus on >> pick one of the terrible things that you wish
to the alleged terrible things. >> Okay, hold on. The alleged
the alleged terrible things. What the [__] did Pisco
do that deserve to get doxed for? >> Well, he didn't get
the brand.
This happened when right in the period where Pis was having all
these arguments with Destiny about all this domination. I think
I think that the day after that big argument he was dox >> that
sorry dub and just to be clear your allegation is that with Steven's
knowledge consent whatever uh >> I don't know if he was
he personally was involved right so
it was Dan either you said some guy said it was Dan's alt >> Yeah.
Okay. The guy that leaked this uh this doxing server um said
that Dan was was banned at alt. So that's what I'm saying that
I've heard. Right. He was correct about he was correct about
the other [__] I don't see there's any >> Wait.
Correct about what? about the existence of the doxing server
that he was able to prove. He's a provis >> the doxing
server that he said was owned by Dan through an alt account.
>> No, I think I think it was Dan's like main account on
the doxing server. >> It was the same one where it was
the same one where they were trying to find his son's family
to smear his family. >> Like they they were they posted
a book or something written by his father to try to pull some
kind of information from him that they could use to smear his
father. >> No, these people were like like Dan >> this
part this part I feel like dubious from the hip on. I'm a little
unaware of this stuff that I'm aware Dan had a server where they
were trying to dox like um Niko Sam's dad. Sorry, not Nikico
Sam's dad. Niko Sam was participating. They were trying to doxan's
dad. But Dan says that that server was for one of his websites,
right? They're trying to find clips for his websites and they
also just happen to be using it for um for doxing Hassan's dad.
>> Well, see when you say smear, I don't know the difference
between smear and >> When I say smear, I mean make up about
them. They can use it to tarnish their public image, right? That's
what that's what I mean by smear. >> Well, help with that.
>> Who Jaw Who Jaws? Do you know >> Jaw who he talks.
>> So, that is a huge convoluted web of on Kiwi farms and
well, to be fair, I'm I'm getting to it, but you've you've come
to me with I think this was Dan's alt account because some guy
said so, but actually, I think it was his main account. I like
>> No, hold on. You're misunderstanding. The the account
on Kiwi Farms is an alt used by Dan. It's the >> How do
you know it's an alt used by Dan? >> The guy who exposed
the doc server. >> The guy
Dan's computer. I'm not Dan's computer. I know you have a very
high bar for for Destiny Clans, but but I'm just telling >> I
just want all of us to observe Lawson's uh bar for Doobie to
prove things, which is appropriate by the way, >> and we'll
see if that that same bar is appropriate for me or anyone else
who has run a foul of this community. We'll see if the bar, you
know,
I believe based on their other behavior, Wargan has been publicly
he's publicly multiple people, by the way, on streams, read out
full names and and he's us
process to get somebody's name and justify him on stream. Like,
he's been doing this for months. Destiny himself has his full
name on it on Twitter. >> I'm aware of that. Yeah. >> Okay.
So, why are you saying it's counterdoxing?
Insane to say about them. Like they from Well, first of all,
let's separate Dan from Destiny. Okay. I don't support everything
Dan does. >> Because they're two people. They're not one
person. >> Okay. But they're working together on a project
very obviously. They've been for years actually. >> What
do you mean what project? >> Destroy
games like Destiny's little attack dog and goes after people.
Like
>> No. No. Destiny has said multiple times on their show
that he does not condone like 90% of what Dan does. >> Trust.
If Destiny can't be held responsible for the things Dan does,
how can I be held responsible for the things Kiwi Farms does?
How the [__] how the could I possibly have that?
How How can I be held responsible? No, Kiryoko, wrong person.
I keep telling them this, but people don't care. >> And
this and this is why he posted the >> No, the trustworthy
sources. Some guy told Doobie that this might be Dan's >> So,
you're saying you're saying that Destiny uh the guy said, "Oh,
he doesn't prove him like all like >> I agree with that.
Should we go into that one?" >> So, why so you you just
I just tried to say it's too convoluted and complicated. Whatever.
No, I was I was saying that and then you said, "Oh, no, it's
a little explain how J." >> Yeah. So, there is very good
reason to believe that Jtock has has like fostered his community
and supported lots of people that have basically either dox Destiny
or dox anybody that Well, hold >> I'm eating the same stuff
I was earlier. Let's see. >> There's a better way to do
it's to report it to the police. >> It's not illegal to
dox people. >> Okay. Sorry. Before before you before we
go there. Hi. Quick. Money. Uh $10.
>> You have no more
boxing is not crime.
Not Fabian's morality. >> Alexander at Doobie. >> Well,
you already said that you support. >> Well, if you call
the police, you should probably give a [__] Fabian,
about what they can do. >> He's a complete idiot. Then
also, how are you certain on the doxing of school by DGG? >> Wait,
I don't think he's an idiot. >> Doxing in and of itself
is
how you obtain that information can be. >> Yeah, it can
be, but it's not. >> Good lord. >> Right. So, just
so if if rape was legal, would you have a problem with rap? >> Um,
I don't know. Maybe. >> Okay. Well, get the out of here.
>> I mean, as a DJ, the obvious answer was
>> Actually, question. the clown like no
you're on an exhibit at a zoo that people come to watch so don't
even does anybody even know what this weirdo looks like or is
he always
>> I know he's very normal looking
fair enough he's very handsome right here >> very sharp
looking guy black one sec one second just we got a super chat
here so DB do you think Dustin's complete it then also how certain
are you are on the back of my piece go by DG thank you Alexander
being so kind I hope you're doing well I haven't seen a but doing
well go ahead >> okay so no I don't think he's completed
it yet I think that in this specific sphere when and he feels
like he's attacked. I think he gets very impulsive and does a
lot of dumb [__] right? And when it comes like very
impulsive, does a lot of dumb [__] I I think that
showing William Mat this right and is I think even if he didn't
have it, just showing it which would imply to somebody that you
do have access to it is dumb as there's no reason to to show
the video title or the video name uh to to say, "Oh yeah, it's
really weird to think that he was uh recording these underage."
There's no reason to show that, right? Yeah. No reason to show
that to win that. Yeah. So >> no reason. >> No reason
at all. >> No reason at all. There's nothing gained from
showing the [__] big I don't know. I'm What was gain
from that? Um well uh Destiny obviously like this guy solo whatever
his name is is probably on Destiny's top 10 most hated list.
So if he can burn him for having like CP okay can we agree on
this then
from the video title
>> okay so I understand that it's very likely that cell
is producing cam and selling it yeah and I think that's what
he found out about the last but let's be clear what the was the
benefit of not just saying that because there are other admits
that this was the case that he was they were recording these
and that was underage at the time you don't need to show the
video title so what was the purpose of show >> so so what
I imagine the purpose to be is for one do you believe that Destiny
did not think that that sorry not DV that Willie Mac was going
to a video like right after their conversation. >> Yeah.
What was the purpose of what was the purpose of the video? >> Okay.
You believe that? Okay. So, if I were Destiny and I'm talking
to Willy M. >> Yeah. And I'm talking to Willie Mack who
is is allegedly making a video to cover like drama or whatever
cuz that's what he does. Like here's some more information about
what I know that this guy probably has on his computer. >> Okay.
Again, there were released last year I think by Destiny even
because there has conversations between him and Solo or them
released by Solo. I'm not sure who releases this. Um where Solo
says that she was underage at the time and in that period and
he says underage at the time these videos were making were like
sex or whatever the [__] That was released last year.
That is that is all Willie M would need to show. There's no reason
to show the top of a video in the video title. Absolutely no
reason he did this. So So even the fact that he did that even
if he doesn't have it on his [__] computer, the fact
that he would do that which would imply to somebody that he does
and then the way that he answered which was when he was asked
was like, "Oh, depends what you're asking." And then he gloated
reason hypothetical for why it might be beneficial to keep it.
I think all this indicates he's a [__] idiot on this
topic. Yes. >> Okay. Do do you have a do you have a steel
man or strongest argument for why he would have it? >> The
strongest the strongest argument is that he genuinely thought
for some reason that his lawyers had instructed him to hold on
to potential cam which I dearly doubt. I I believe they told
no >> the I mean the strongest argument is he just didn't
want to tell his lawyers because he might have been scared that
his lawyers might have had a duty to report it >> the whole
thing the message or whatever anything put up in discovery but
the cam itself no I I think if he had told him hey I have a reason
to believe this person is underage I do not believe Destiny's
high price lawyers would have told him to save that on his computer
or on USB or whatever the [__] >> and share
it on discord messages >> yeah [__] disc
you need to get get out take it to the police and and let them
follow up on this because it's like the sale in production absolutely
>> like someone had blur the video. >> I will say
that almost certainly, okay, almost certainly I not almost certainly
I've never seen any definitive proof that the person who was
doing like all the pro DG doxing was Dan. Never seen anything
to indicate that. Okay. Um or I've never seen anything like credible
or conclusive to indicate that. It's like one person's like theory
that that's who it is. Um I do think Dan's been involved in doxing.
I don't know that like that specific person that they're referring
to from the Kiwi Farms thread is uh is Dan. I have not seen conclusive
evidence of that. So
anyway, just throwing that out there. >> You have to Someone
had to edit the videos to blur them. No, >> can I I want
to ask a question. Uh >> with one hand, I'm guessing >> if
we're going to say if we're going to say if we're going to say
um that like Well, yes, Destiny docs JTO, but Jtock had it coming
because he cultivated a community that led to other docses. Um,
could Duby not say the exact same claim about the community that
Destiny has created that led to peace talks? >> He absolutely
could and I would want to see proof of that. >> When you
say proof of that, like what what what kind of proof >> happened?
No, no, hold on. Because we're talking like something much more
nebulous because when it comes to like J talks, it's very explicit,
right? He doxes him. But the allegation that well, he deserved
it because he cultivated a community that led some people in
the community to dox some other people. >> This is like
a second this is like a second order removed consequence down.
I could just simply post I could just simply send you a video
of Destiny being critical of Pisco and that would be enough to
satisfy the standard. >> No, so is anybody familiar with
JTO's like server and the the people that he surrounds himself
with? >> This is also real quick. This was actually heartbreaking
for me because Jysical was one of my favorite Destiny orbiters
back in the day. And I don't know if anybody's familiar with
the timeline of when uh got his fully erect uh Destiny hate,
but the timeline is very convenient with when he started dating
uh Cherry. >> Wait, no, it's not
totally made up
>> hold on. >> Oh, hold on. What's up? >> That
is a lie. You are literally no person's favorite. They are always
lying to you. >> Thank you. Love you, too. >> Clear.
Cherry. Cherry is the one that that Destiny recorded her without
her consent. And then >> that's not even true. >> How
do you know that's not true? >> How do you know it is true?
>> Okay. Again, so what I'm saying is Cherry is the one
that said that this that Destiny did this and she has at least
there's at least one. No, I'm sorry. Hold on. First of all, first
of >> uh, all this Lawson guy would have to do is come
on stream. He's like too scared to come on stream because he
doesn't want to he doesn't want to actually have this conversation.
That's weird. >> You guys are gonna You guys are going
to sit here and like flip me because someone says this guy recorded
this chick without her consent. And I say, "What's the proof
of that? Are you serious? You want proof of it?" Well, yeah.
Yes. Because defaultly it's not true until it's proven true.
>> Okay. So So again, >> okay. So prove that the
server is that I surround myself with people like this or prove
any of this. Lawson, you got to prove any of this >> is
not how truth work. >> One second. One second. So my understanding
of the cherry thing is >> they'll they'll keep moving forward
without him proving anything right
prove anything bro anything >> that she was recorded without
her consent apparently multiple times and this was shared at
least I think >> she didn't say that >> yes and then
there are other people who have verified that they either received
or or uh those recordings from Destiny or that uh after she found
out she showed them to show proof that she was uh that this actually
happened and and then I think the person >> can we can
we zoom in on verified and which people these are >> no
dude cuz we keep we keeping past what actually matters >> I'm
on the same thing I'm on the same Okay, go ahead. So, and then
the person who allegedly got this right um from Rose's DMs posted
a snippet of it on like Twitter like I think like the first 10
seconds or something, right? So, like that's that's everything
that Terry has to back up her position and she's
confident she's confident enough that this is actually true that
she filed a police report. So far, hasn't gotten it yet, but
she's filed a police report. Um and while Destiny has this, no,
not true. And so, and rather than when I brought this up, you
didn't say that, oh, we're not sure this or it hasn't been confirmed.
You say no, it's not >> Yes. Because when someone's accused
of something and they don't like have any proof for it, yes,
my default is it's not true. >> You need to like leak her
revenge. So somehow when it goes to Cherry and her accusations
against Destiny, oh, if there's no proof of it, well, it's not
true. But with Destiny's proof against me, it's like pictures
of cat photos and pictures of what? People mocking him in my
server. And that's proof. It's uh what is it? Us talking with
the the exclamation point at the end. That's proof.
Is this guy out of his mind? >> And tiles today. So >> how
would she prove this to you? >> What? How would she prove
this? >> How would she prove that she was recorded without
Well, how does she know she was recorded without her consent?
>> Because she has copies of the recording. Okay, that
would be a start. >> You want copies of the [__]
recordings? >> Well, well, dude, >> is it DG or I
I don't know what else to >> You understand? You're asking
for a standard that would no one would ever accept ever. >> What
do you understand that? >> No, dy. I have recordings of
you outside my window videotaping me jacking off and I didn't
know you were there. I have them though. >> So, where do
we go? Where do we go from >> We have four people. >> What
people? Okay, this is why I wanted to stop you because what people
are you talking about >> and what names every single name
ever interacted with the situation? Yes, that's why I asked you
[__] >> Alexander win.
>> So I would say is Lawson like super
>> he says he says uh $10 I says she was not record
>> uh no this is also wrong Alexander Ren she was recorded
without her consent >> without her consent. It was shared
without her consent
that's not the claim could be wrong. the claim could be wrong,
but that's not the thing. The claim is that she was recorded
without her consent and it was shared without her consent and
she learned of the recording because of the Yeah, it was audio
recording. Um, that she learned of the recording because of it
being shared. >> Well, because of it being doxed from being
shared, >> paying to By the way, these embarrassing
are massive pay pigs. The Alexander guy, the Lawson guy, the
Lawson guy is the biggest pay pig. I don't want this loser back
in my community. He is embarrassing. Okay? I don't care how much
money he spends. He donates 100 bucks, 200 bucks to Wick at the
drop of a hat. This loser, get him the away from me. That is
the claim, >> right? Okay. So, again, they're like, I think
uh Queen um Jaw uh that the girl's name. Um one of the ones that
said she received it. I forgot her name, but she wasn't in J's
crew, if that's what you're thinking. Uh she said on Twitter,
Twitter that she received it, she told Cherry about it. I forget
her [__] name. It's like um is it like Abby or something?
I can't remember her [__] name, but there's like
three or four people that three or four people who said they've
seen this, right? Um and that it exists and that it's real, right?
So, and given his this the other behavior that was that was made
uh public at the time, which is sharing of people's news and
show without consent and recording people recording audio of
people very uh which one audio stop. Wait, can don't please don't
pile stuff on one at a time. Please,
>> by the way, this guy's like super down to debate this.
I've offered him to come on stream. I've said, "Bro, come on
stream like a hundred times. Why is he terrified to get on my
stream? Why'd he hop on the stream with these people? Why would
he have hopped on? I was so nice to this guy in DMs. You have
no idea. all the reasons, but I think it's it's very likely that
it's true. Okay, more likely than that, it's true. So, one of
the other reasons is that there was another recording that was
released of him with some dude that was just audio and he took
it in his pocket, right? And oh, well, some people get nervous
and when this was brought up, it's like, oh, some people get
nervous with the camera so I recorded in my pocket. That's [__]
nonsense. I'm sorry. Like, no. So, um, so I just I think it's
very likely that based on all this, right, and probably some
other things I'm forgetting right now that this happened to Cherry
and he did this, right? So, so Destiny's response of this is
no, not true. Then, yeah, I have no reason to believe him about
this one because he's lied about so many other >> This
is a different different allegation. None of them are true. >> Which
ones are true? Me? All of them. I >> All of them. You think?
Hold on. Wait. Hold on. Do you think that I'm wrong about him
lying about so many other things? Like >> Well, maybe.
Wait, I need specifics. >> Oh my god. >> Well, dude,
don't give me this. Oh my god. This is This is the problem I
have. Look, this is why. Look, Dooby. Doobie, I've done this.
I've had the same conversation against DJs about you, how Dubby's
a Nazi, and Doobie said this and Doobie said that, and they just
keep piling on and nobody and nobody ever wants to go into like
the details of why. They just want to say, "Wow, you want to
argue about this one thing even though we know all this other
[__] about this person when a lot of the other shit's
not true either." And that's what's happening. >> Hold
on. Hold on. I don't even >> I
every one of these people just gets away from this idea that
you have to prove some association between my community and Kiwi
Farms to like even make this argument, right? Some some association,
by the way, that I'm that I'm aware of and enforce and
am against moderating, right? Like that's what you have to argue
because obviously individual people could come in and like post
something and I would, you know, moderate that and there's nothing
I can do to control that, right? But you have to make you have
to make this argument and say that it's something that I refuse
to moderate that I encourage that I've like perpetually had which
is >> Even need the other pattern the rest of the patterns
of dishonesty. >> Okay. Okay. >> Unless you want
to go through each one. >> This is just No, no, no, no.
This is the >> right? This is No, this is it's important
to do the meta. Like what we have here is we have I'm assuming
some cult member um that can't accept reality because he's too
in love with the concept of Destiny and DGG. But but I'm working
with insufficient evidence. That's just my first assumption.
And there's this tactic where you're trying to establish several
things as a pattern. He wants to go through each one, present
a different counter-argument, and muddy the waters with each
thing because he doesn't want to deal with the overarching narrative
that he's already accepted, which is that Destiny is an immoral
degenerate, right? Because which is >> I'm actually rubber
in your glue. So, checkmate. Go on, Die. >> No, wait. I
don't ask. I don't ask like you're talking about like going like
one one by one. >> Well, yeah, because I very quickly however
quickly we can do it. What is the What is the sufficient evidence
here that Jtock was personally involved in doxing people that
would give >> Yes. Oh, Lactoid. Beautiful. I always say
this, Lacto is a fantastic debater. I understand a lot of people
don't like him for some reason, but he is a really good debater
and he's actually good at pointing out like, hey, this is the
thing that's like like this this is the premise that you are
most weak on, like you are most vulnerable on, and this is the
premise I'm going to keep hammering. >> It would be right
to for death to destiny to dox him. >> Jtock was personally
directly. >> Remember, JTO was the one who was doxed and
so what did he do to justify that to be clear? >> Yes,
I I believe it was counterdoxing. >> Okay, so what did
he do? All right, let me pull it up. Hold on. >> He had
a community of people who hated Destiny and doxed them and therefore
should suffer the crimes of his >> Can I post in uh prime?
I've never used stream blast
>> and the discord. Yeah, the discord group
>> All right. I just want on record I'm going to post evidence
before Jimmy did just on record. >> Oh god. >> Noted
for don't go me. Don't go me. >> I'm going to point I'm
going to point out the different standard that I'm >> he's
getting fed from Destiny. I don't care who he's getting fed from.
Listen, I keep getting told that I'm guilty of this, right? I
keep getting told this over and over again. If they have some
evidence and something I can action on, then I'd love to action
on it and show them that I don't want this. This isn't something
I want. And by the way, even if they have evidence now, I've
asked repeatedly. You have to show me some kind of evidence of
something so I can moderate it because I don't support this.
But instead, they like hold all of this evidence back and they're
like, "Well, here's some people talking about how Destiny looks
weird in this picture. That's evidence." No, it's not disliking.
Guess what? Disliking ev disliking Destiny is not a doxable offense.
If you're trying to create the a world where thinking Destiny
is a disgusting loser is worth doxing someone over, you you are
a loser. Okay? Like it's so insane that that's clearly what they're
trying to do. If you think Destiny's a disgusting loser and you
want to say that a lot, um we should be able to dox you. Actually,
you're like basically a Kiwi farmer and uh we should be able
to dox you. You you should get >> Hey, hey, Scott, while
he's while Lawson's working on that, um what would be wrong?
I mean, like from like an argumentative stance to do what he
was what he's doing, right? He's saying, "Hey, you're presenting
you're presenting a lot of data, right? You're telling me all
these things, but like unless we establish that these individual
um instances are actually true, then the overarching narrative
is untrue." What would be wrong? >> There's nothing there's
nothing wrong with isolating argument. >> Is anybody in
a server with Lactoid so I can add him on Discord? Cuz I would
love to add him and just ask like, "Hey, could you just tell
me like what they posted? Is it like Lactoid TV?" No. I'm going
to try to add Lactoid and I'll see if it's got the same uh Does
it have like the same It's got the same thing. We'll see if this
guy adds me. Yeah, that's that's that's him. Mutual friends,
mutual servers.
>> Yeah, I got him. Hold on. >> You mentioned handling
them one at a time. There is something wrong with isolating arguments
one at a time and then attempting to introduce new counter arguments
that move into a different direction and subvert the conversation
so that Doobie has to try and regain control of the conversation
so that we're on some relevant topic and then constantly subverting
with one at a time so that the conversation turns into nothing
because you notice we haven't gotten anywhere on anything. And
it's mostly because you brought on this stupid clown to just
act like a stupid. >> You're right, baby. You guys are
making hell of progress before I got here on getting to the bottom
of things. Okay. Uh, but well, thank you for answering that.
I mean, all right, that's it's an answer. Um, I just love to
see this, man. I just want to see it. Could I see it? Oh, did
this just crash again? Dude, I'm going to lose it. >> I'm
like, I'm 30. >> YouTube YouTube is straight up dog right
now. I don't know what's going on that is, right? So, >> you
can nobody and nobody ever wants to go into like the details
of why. Hold on. He had a community of people who hated Destiny
and Dustin these things but like unless we establish that
nothing because you notice
>> haven't gotten anywhere on anything and it's mostly
because you brought on this stupid [__] clown to
just act like a >> right you guys are making hell of progress
for I got here on getting to the bottom of things. >> Okay.
U but I thank you for answering that. I mean All right. That's
an answer. Um >> look I I I look I don't this is black.
Wait one thing. This is this is where I sympathize with you guys
because this is exhausting. This is something that does take
like hours and hours and hours because it all goes back to like
the Anavoir and like the like 15-year-old he said was hot like
eight years ago and like other like it >> I don't shut
the [__] up and post the evidence, bro. Take as much
time as you want, but shut the [__] up and post the
evidence. This is all we're here for. >> It is exhausting.
So, I will uh you know, I will cut you some slack on that. There's
there's also and like I said I think it's good to go like and
that's why I asked you specifically about the JTOK thing just
because you know when I saw the fact that they doxed him and
I also the death threats and everything I thought this was like
pretty extreme like this was sort of crossing the Rubicon in
terms of just kind of like I didn't think a streamer this big
would be doing stuff like this like this is pretty wild right
um but to give like a little bit of uh credit here as well like
when you have somebody who has such a long history as Destiny
does in this space you can't like especially like on a panel
like this where we got what three hours three and a half hours
we can't possibly go in depth on every single one of these >> right
sometimes you just have to likely mention Right? And you say,
"Look, this is like part of pattern behavior. Don't you remember
XYZ?" And you could say, "Well, but let's like go into XYZ."
We don't have time to go into XYZ. I mean, Xone is right. So,
>> but you can you can go into X though and
my theory as to why this was done was because I think that J
was threatening the brand. But also, this kind of behavior is
like particularly egregious. Like as streamers or even just internet
people, I think that all of us would be pretty or I guess maybe
are pretty terrified of somebody who's dramatically more powerful
than us putting in resources into doxing us and making death
threats to us. That kind of scared me a little. I'll tell you
right now. I'm doxed. I'm finding the person who doxed me and
going to them like
>> But you're not going to break through the noise. >> Oh
god. No. >> Look, I've done this. I've had the same >> or
even >> I'm so I think that all
>> this guy this guy's crazy to say that. Jesus Christ.
>> I'm sorry. Like this is part of like I power dynamics
are usually like memes, right? But there is something here as
to like if a multi-millionaire is trying to come after you and
you're not that you're kind of at a huge disadvantage. >> Yeah,
leftist power dynamics are actually completely correct. Not just
memes. Um but anyway, uh Fairy Queen, FQ. Um that's a nice picture
of you right there. >> No, Fairy Queen, stop donating money
to get him off track. Fairy Queen >> um says, "Ask Lawson
how Destiny knows that Rose had with like 10 different guys in
the video." Um which he says in the Willy Mack DMs if he didn't
possess or view the CP on his computer. Uh, so >> first
of all, fairy queen, love you, miss you. Hope you're doing good.
Um, I'm sure he saw them. I'm I'm my my contention is not Destiny
never viewed I mean what's what's probably now child. >> Well,
it was CP Thin, too. >> Sure. Yeah. I'm just saying like
I'm sure he did. >> Whether or not he whether or not he
knew is is, you know, up for the mysteries of the universe, right?
Like I mean maybe he knew, maybe he didn't know that. Like >> the
contention is whether or not he kept >> Um,
we don't have proof that he still has it on his computer, guys.
>> He handled it responsibly. What's the percentage chance
of it being CP? Like 99%
99.8%
99%. Like 95% maybe. Maybe I can bring it back a little bit.
95% >> He clearly either didn't handle it responsibly at
all or he's just lying to people to like so that he can because
he's a 5D chess genius and then later he'll show that he did
actually handle it responsibly and that it was >> that's
that's the thing is like this this is like the cope, right? What
Fabian's laying out right here is people are like, "No, you don't
understand. Like he might just be baiting people." It's like
baiting people into think he's this guy like he's actually if
that were actually the case. If he were like baiting people and
think he's a he's worse than a I don't know what is worse than
a but it's whatever Destiny would be if he was like doing some
kind of 5D chess to make other people look stupid by baiting
them to calling him a that would be insane. >> All lies
and smoking mirrors. Um, I mean like there, you know, I could
sprout wings and fly potentially, but all of the available evidence
that we have points to the fact that he is wildly at at minimum
is a dude in his mid-30s constantly going after teenagers and
not really giving a underage or not um in any real way and is
using his power and influence to try and um, you know, garner
that, maybe make some careers and, you know, um, and and that's
a [__] problem. And then when people reach out to
him, he is wildly handling this wrong and is maintaining um,
childborn on his computer for some reason. Um, and that this
is a a relative pattern of behavior, not necessarily the CP,
but in constantly being involved in drama and in bullying and
in potential um, >> destroying these teams lives, these
20-year-olds lives. >> I mean, I mean, he's made a few
20-year-olds lives, too, to be fair. Um, but, uh, >> but
I mean, that's what you get when you go with Destiny. You got
to roll the dice whether or not your life is ruined or whether
or not you get a career. And he's, you know, you know, it's kind
of like a Harvey Weinstein, you know, maybe if you just bend
over on the on the on the couch, >> except on a long enough
time scale, everybody's life is ruined, right? Like, who's known
this guy long term? other than Dan who's independently wealthy
before he met Destiny who's known this guy in like a long enough
term and their life hasn't been with significantly basically
right like there's there's basically like maybe you could argue
V although from what I understand V and Molina's relationship
that was pretty and both of them had a pretty up experience with
each other right Moot uh I think Moot had some pretty bad experiences
with Destiny's community I maybe that comes up to a wash Bose
Bose ended up you know exploding her own platform so true but
I I am saying that like there are not very many people who interact,
stay around longterm, and aren't like somehow within the end.
>> Ouch for them, you can have a career in this industry.
>> Oh, no. Um, Alexander win $5 says, "My apologies if
they can't fix it. No problem. Um, we all mistakes. Not a big
deal." Sorry, there's so many. >> Another 19-year-old like
it's just Well, even if they once again, I think it's morally
disgusting to be skirting like you're you're 36. You're scrolling
Discord for 18, 19year-old. >> You know what? I'm I am
ecstatic that we can all land on mild social conservatism being
the right way to conduct your personal affairs. I'm happy we
all agree on that. >> Just being a norm, bro. I wanted
to talk about that counter points um because I had a larger conversation
with someone else offline about uh this uh very issue um and
and we just don't have time to get it because it's going to be
inflamm it's going to be extremely inflammatory. Um but u I I
I I I think that okay very very quickly right um I think it's
there's something to be said about people who uh tend to have
like a prediliction for those who are much younger than them
right um like and they like establish a pattern um like that
type of person that sounds like a red flag to me right nothing
else that sounds like a red flag >> liberals and progressives
looks like a paraphilic right so here's here's actually part
of my beef because because I actually do have >> am I the
only one uh am I the only one who's sitting here like uh this
lost Harrison guy posted nothing he's not posted anything yet.
Can I Can I find Is this guy serious? He was just arguing it's
counterdoxing. He knows it's counterdoxing. How does he know
it's counterdoxing when he when he doesn't he hasn't presented
any evidence? Where's the evidence? Where's the evidence? Where's
the evidence? >> A I don't know 30% 40% crossover with
DG. Okay. And and this is my beef. So, liberalism maximum human
liberty. Uh effectively like it doesn't really make a prescription
past the age of 18. It says like, "Oh, you're an adult. Pursue
your happiness." And actually when you make a whole bunch of
Conor saying that nobody cares about >> a series of like
millionaire women, right, who who are otherwise amazing and completely
compatible with him, right? And could it be the love of his life?
But he says no because they have as much power as I do, right?
And power. >> No, no,
it is more ethical to be gay. >> That's that's that's interesting
because sexism. Let me let me just just get out. Let me just
get out the thesis. Okay. Right. um is that like just because
you happen to uh be involved with a person where there's a power
some sort of power imbalance does not necessarily tell me on
its face that there's a problem right if there's a larger pattern
that's different right or if I can see inside this relationship
if I can examine it and examine the the mechanisms of that relationship
people but I think people
inherently evil in that regard >> the literally the only
thing I tuned into this for was uh was just watching this part
just the part where this guy postes evidence >> I think
the the problem um what I would say is that you know it's Even
in even in a power dynamic, it's not necessarily a power dynamic,
but there's a problem. The problem is does the person that is
in the the submissive or the subservient or the lower
capitalize on that so you can take advantage of their inexperience
so you can get access to cheap gratifying.
I'm also I'm also Let's also be honest. If you're constantly
looking at the 18-year-olds and that's who you're targeting,
if the law was 17, we all know that they'd be waiting until they
turn 17.
I I'm just saying this Lost and Harrison guy said it was counterdoxing
and he feels confident it's counteroxing. He there is evidence.
He has to have the evidence. If he thinks the evidence is in
Destiny's VOD of Destiny saying he proved it, you are you are
okay. And I I think this guy should be enough of a non-coward
to come and admit that he doesn't have that evidence. >> Me,
too. But this expand this expands into a moral prescription,
by the way. And people keep saying like, "Oh, you have no morals.
You have no principles." I've been with my wife for 13 years.
I haven't had any other emotional or physical relationships with
any other person in that entire time. I have two children. I'm
a relatively >> pretty emotional between us. I don't >> But
but that's more like a fraternal love than a love cry. So any
you have may have personal morals. I think people are just people
myself included calling you out for willing to to willing to
work with people that don't have those morals. >> But I
think that but I think that especially in this space though um
I I think that Fabian, you and I are the only person that are
married and have >> I'm married and have kids. >> Well,
I'm married. I'm married and I will have a kid in March. >> Oh,
actually Dubie does as well. Okay. All right. Hold on. Duby's
marriage is a marriage. Only people. >> You know what?
You know what? I stand corrected. I'm just kidding. I love you.
>> I would forward the argument that two or three years
ago, it's actually kind of funny how time changed things. Uh
two or three years ago, 70% 80% of Twitch poll panels were 100%
like, >> you know, 18 to 30year-olds who were promiscuous,
respect workers, who were single,
family, and all that. >> Jesse isn't an out of control
party boy. He's more like a flasher on the street corner. The
violation is is the turn on in that of itself. >> Girl
knows about inappropriate. That's for goddamn sure. >> Destiny
isn't an out of control party boy. He's more like a flasher on
the street corner. The violation is the turn uh on the the violation
is the turn on in that of itself. >> Okay. Okay. Can I
can I respond to Queen after Conor? >> Well, yeah. If I
if I can be brief. Wait, I brought this last somebody's breaking
up. Uh so I brought this like rubbing his hands together. >> This
is the this is the danger of the hyonic treadmill. Okay. If you're
unfamiliar with the concept, go ahead and take a look at it.
>> Yourself, Conor, you get your money. >> Um, actually,
if you give into degeneracy, then you'll just seek more degeneracy
in an infinite loop and then you become a worse person. But I'll
keep supporting this person unconditionally with no changes on
their part because it makes me money
yourself in a video game. Don't actually do it. I don't want
to break the TOS. Okay. >> Over the years and bring back
all black everything. I would actually love to. Um, we just need
more reliable guests. It's really the long and short of it. >> Like
Connor, all Connor needs to do just show up to these things and
say, "I don't care who he hurts. He makes me money. It's way
shorter. You save us all a whole bunch of time and we don't care
about. We understand that you've justified this to yourself.
Go ahead. Justify to nobody cares, right? Just say, "I I don't
care how much he hurts people. I'm going to let him keep doing
that as long as it makes me money." That's all you got to say,
Connor. Stop pretending to like have some moral grounding to
this. You don't. >> If I had more black people to bring
in the space and have him be able to come on week after week,
I would absolutely do it. >> He is available and it's something
to consider. and do and do. Oh my god, we had a whole thing about
this already that right. So, so at some point, you know, if you're
not committed in a monogous relationship, which I understand
if it's the ideal for me, it's not the idea, etc. as he's as
>> I never contested that. >> Yes, you did. You asked
me. You asked >> Okay, finally. These guys are >> Sorry,
I've been switching between like
>> Oh, my bad. I provided as much proof as everyone else
did. Oh, so he didn't he come at Dubbie and say, "Oh, just for
the record, I'm like giving more proof than Duby, dude. I'm giving
proof before Dubie." And he's given nothing.
You're saying okay hold provide some kind of proof. Okay. And
that is yes. Okay. It's in the group cam. So when he's asked
by Willie Mac uh if you're sending me this I'm guessing you still
have that video. His response is oh guess why? It depends on
what you're asking. And then but yes I created a copy. Yada yada
yada. So like he's asked he's asked >> I never contested
that. >> Yes you did. You asked me why.
>> Oh why do you believe he stole his cam on his computer?
Yes. You contested that. You literally asked why Duby believes
he stole the cam. >> You ask me what proof I have that
he saw the video. >> Yeah. Yeah, I don't know. Is that
he had the video? >> Collection child porn. But I'm telling
you, he's he that he still had the video when he responded to
J to Willie Mack. He said, "Yes, I had it." Like that. That's
what he said. >> Okay. C can we agree that that uh Willie
Mack did call the police? Yes. >> I'm guessing the police
take child fairly seriously. >> I hope so. >> I hope
so. Which you are
experiences over the years. In fact, I >> Yeah. He just
slips the cops a h 100red when they come in and they don't care
about CP anymore. Um yeah. So, I imagine if he did get the police
called on him that I don't think he would have streamed today
if that were the case. >> Okay. So, hold on. So, have you
gone from uh you know, we we shouldn't we shouldn't think we
shouldn't think that he actually had this on his computer to
uh well, he hasn't been charged with anything that we're aware
of, so we should just trust him. Like I said, >> well,
I'm I'm operating from the assumption that Destiny isn't a complete
idiot. And if he did have that on >> Unfortunately, this
guy,
listen, I love Rei. Unfortunately, this guy watched Rey's argument.
Guys, I'm operating from the B point of view that like Destiny's
maybe not a complete
and um yeah, I'm operating from that point of view. Why? Why?
Why would you operate from that point of view? Sounds pretty
dumb. >> At this point, because he's just because he's
not. And I don't believe you believe that he is either. >> Hold
on. I do think Hold on. On this issue, interpersonal >> here.
Here's the thing. I think Destiny's pathological. Is he a complete
in every aspect of his life? Obviously not. But he keeps making
decisions that make no logical dissense. uh no logical sense
in this realm. There is something pathological going on. Something
is not engaging logically in his brain before he goes and does
things. Right. The and the better proof of this honestly better
proof than just telling Lily Mack that you have child on your
computer which is already maybe the most thing Destiny's ever
done. But there is something more and that is while you're trying
to spin a narrative that all of your ops are connected to kiwi
farms and they're the reason people get doxed, you provide doxing
information while taunting the same kiwi farmers you're trying
to tie to other people by taunting those same people saying take
this information and try to dox her. You give a bunch of doc
a bunch of PII about that person who is the minor you sent to
Kiwi Farms so that they can dox her.
Which one of those two decisions leads you to believe that Destiny's
decision-making in this realm is not tainted, is not broken?
Because both of those two decisions are completely insane. >> And
his weirds on the other
would an intelligent person share uh someone's news with with
somebody that they just met uh with in under a week. Would an
intelligent person do that? I would say no. He did that. >> Yeah,
maybe.
What? Is that is that is that a stupid thing to do or is that
a reckless thing to do or is that >> the implication would
be that it's not an intelligent thing to do? The By the way,
the implication that intelligent people don't make bad decisions
is also
>> If we if we if we go off of what fairy queen was saying,
right? We assume this to be true. I'm not saying this is true,
right? I'm just offering a possibility. We go off of the concept
that Destiny is in a situation where he is addicted to the drama,
addicted to the kind of the the the fear of getting caught, addicted
to doing the perverse, then it is per if if we assume that to
be part of the paraphilia that that is that is enrapturing Destiny's
experiences. Um, then it's perfect. Yeah, I said assume like
seven times, right? Allegedly. Fair enough, right? Um, yeah.
No. Then then it's perfectly reasonable to assume that Destiny
can be a I mean, it's not reasonable to assume that he's like
super smart, but that he can be in a slightly above average IQ
person or like, you know, 115 IQ, whatever metric in that area
you want you want to grab and still engage in very stupid behavior
in those instances because they would be wrapped up together.
Just like just like a a streaker, just like a flasher, right?
the idea that they're like ooh the idea of getting caught or
oh yeah I have like there's it's not unreasonable that he might
do stupid things in terms of showing what people what he has
because his his paraphilia both of these things can actually
you know the potentially danger queen was looking for >> are
moral but if I created my entertainment to match my morals I'd
be significantly less which I really appreciate so much she says
do you think Ted Buddy Ted Bundy attacked the sort of girls at
Florida State because what would degenerate
>> yeah that also >> well I need to leave in a moment
so I'll answer briefly degenerate 150 years ago um was actually
understood as a statement about life where if you engage in good
behavior.
I'll secure the
>> Actually, 150 years ago, degenerate meant something
totally different than what fairy queen means here or anyone
means when we actually talk about it. And uh I'm just going to
throw that out there cuz it's really important that I do that
cuz I got to go right away. Also, I'm going to lift some more
weights. Just give me a second. Dude, do I provide facts relevant
to the findings regarding details of the event destin
format with confidence to me. Um so, thank you Audacity um for
that attestation. Thank you for the kind $10. Okay. Um >> I'll
answer the question enough for me. So I I will say this because
maybe he was regarded towards me towards me. I don't know. I
will say that Ted Bundy um may have engaged in those attacks
due to degenerate um behavior. I will agree with points to some
degree. I mean predominantly primarily it's because he's you
know as ASPD, right? He was a psychopath, right? I mean as a
personality disorder and what what causes personality disorders
is is a subject for a lot of debate even even in in like there's
a lot there. Um but I would say that there are What are you doing?
What is that noise? >> Sorry, I apologize. I keep my Don't
worry about it. >> Wait, what is Fairy Queen talking about?
What? I don't even What? How did that make any sense?
>> I was thinking it, but I wasn't going to say it. I didn't
want to go there for the memes, but >> hopefully that's
not please. >> It is a real job. Jewish. >> I have
a real job. Put on my hands. >> I should know white people.
I don't know where you >> It's not. Remember, it's not
racist if it's targeted towards white people. >> Excuse
me. Jeez, not white. First of all, that's not what I said. I
will not let that stand. I didn't say that. >> Black save
us by having sex. >> 18-year-old specifically, but young
people, legal adults. Okay. Legal adults as a young people. Yeah.
And my question is like very like uh it's very straightforward,
right? It's based on the premise of like if someone can [__]
me up, why can't I [__] You're telling me that this
person is so impressionable and easily manipulated that like
you know I can't like get with them yet they're able to like
decide my fate on the political level. They can vote they're
both equal to mine. The >> problem is you [__]
people over like in a revenge way I don't
like they're so easily manipulated like manipulated that like
they can't even have sex like 18 years old and then they shouldn't
be able to decide what we'll
actually I disagree with some other people who are like oh we
should raise
>> look I think this is a good opportunity for you. There's
college money there. You didn't get good grades and like you
kind of straight >> I'm like I'm just trying to >> look
it. The only time this will occur is if the not libertarian okay
anyway. Um, before you leave, yeah, before you leave, I had a
question for the panel that I want to answer to. So, you have
two choices, gentlemen. One is a 16-year-old Amish girl. The
other is a 30-year-old woman inhabitant of North Central Island.
>> Make your choice.
>> I get the only one who gets this. Okay. North Island
is like a super remote island with like a tribal peoples that
are like gener.
Yeah. Yeah. And they just discovered >> Okay. I'm not going
to give you the clip. I got to go to bed. By the way, yeah, sure.
Okay. My name's Connor. I run down the wonderful war. It's fantastic.
Go check out. It's my most successful channel. I'm also trying
to count politics and val network. Counterpoints politics. Just
Google Just find out all the information I can find now. We know
these public doc just I'm not aware of anybody that a dox there's
no evidence that they can connect to any do himself and Daniel
himself having doxing people. We know this. >> Yeah. I
understand. >> So I don't understand. Okay. So why would
they call it counterdoc if it were shown to you that Jessica
was doing what I claim he is doing? Would that make a >> Yeah
of course it would make a difference. Would make a difference.
But also but also why do you believe it when you don't have the
evidence? You can't even describe it. Just describe the evidence
that makes you think this. Please describe any of the evidence.
Uh, hey unrelated. Veto put out his comic a couple days ago.
Lots of good reviews all over Twitter for him. Uh, the only review
I've seen is from Derson himself and says it's Cherry. So, I
trust on this one. Okay. I trust unfortunately. Uh, he said that
Veto's comic is dog. I have no idea why he'd do that to his co-host.
Seems kind of up. The only thing I've seen is is talking and
going, "Look, look. He plagiarized the gun. He plagiarized the
gun."
Is a hater for a living.
is a hater. He is. He's a dick. >> Okay. But all you're
saying is that he cultivated a community where people were doxing
uh Hutch. So far we know. Um but if if that's >> dude I
want this Lost guy to come I I so badly want him to come on stream
right >> If that's a standard Well, Destiny himself and
Dan himself were publicly saying they're going to dox people
while the community was trying to dox people and saying doxing
base yada yada. So like if that's a standard, how the [__]
is that counter? The person, again, I'll say the person who actually
originated Hutch's docs is somebody who was in Dan's server discussing
doxing Hassan Piker's dad. That they're the same guy. They're
the same guy. The person who originated Hutch's docs is the guy
who's in Dan's server trying to dox Hassan Piker's dad. And that
gets blamed on me somehow. You come to you come to me and blame
that on me. What >> if if what say a community being cultivated
where people were doxing Hutch, right, so far? How is how is
it a counterdox when Destiny himself and Dan himself are involved
in organizing doxing at the times of people? >> Because
like Okay, trying to think of how to how to phrase this. Sorry
for >> think this hard brother. >> Well, it's difficult.
Looking
I need to post this really quickly. Um because the guy who um
the script that I just posted where the guy talks about docsing
President Sunday at Dan's direction, President Sunday um acknowledged
that that same guy called Niko Sam I think it is reached out
to him directly and apologized for that like like months prior,
right? So, President Sunday believes that this guy was involved
in his docks and this guy is admitting publicly that he was involved
in the docks at Dan's right. >> Dan's direction.
>> And what what guy is it? >> A guy called Niko
Sam, I think it is. >> And who is that?
>> Do we believe that Lost Harrison is a Destiny super
fan? Does have has no idea who Nikico Sam is. That's like a little
Dude, he he also said he's a big fan of mine. Like, did he miss
the whole Tom Foolery thing as well? I don't know if I believe
that. Do we believe that? I don't know if we believe that. Okay.
So, he's uh one of the people that was involved in the Kiwi farms.
I'm posting doces on Kiwi Farms. Um doces of people that were
like anti-destiny basically. I think the one the specific one
he talks about is the is president Sunday and um and also the
Hassan docs group and I posted the Hassan docs group about that.
>> Oh, Nico Sam by the way. >> Uh Alexander win while
we're waiting on that. Uh $10. Libertarians and HayQ are a lot
like leftist morality or conservatives in Christianity. They
never shut up about it and you the stories. Um but they're nowhere
to be found. Um thank you Alexander Win for the kind uh $10.
Yeah, I bring it up all the time. >> The lacto likes to
bring that up. Um, and uh, a leftist in morality. Do I >> I
think uh, me and Cory went over it. Cory, you would agree that
uh, libertarians have very high accuse compared to they do score
pretty low in empathy. Um, but they do have very high >> Uh,
yeah. As in I would agree with that. Uh, I personally would not
take the trade-off with empathy. Personally, >> did he
leave? >> I mean, it is midnight. It is past midnight.
It's like >> But I mean, he was in the middle of uh, you
know, reading this. >> It could have been an accident.
So, what's what's what's uh what's your line for for like when
when when does Trump do too much to piss you off? What's the
line for you? I want to know cuz I keep seeing you on Twitter
defending yourself in that like, yeah, I'll call him out. I'll
criticize the I'll criticize the >> I know you do, but
like you know, much to like, you know, like people who are on
Destiny side, like how much bull are you going to have to be
embarrassed by before you're like, "Hey, you know what? Maybe
it was just a bad choice." >> what's the line for you?
You want to know what
>> Lawson guy leaves. >> I don't know exactly where
the line is. I'll give you a list of a couple things that he
could do. Yeah. Well, >> he returns.
>> Trying to I'm trying to get this guy to come on the
stream. Okay. Trying to get this guy to get on
>> a full IQ test for those cognitive ability tests for
the research that you're doing. >> I think I think that
IQ I think that IQ tests are some of the most means tested tests
in all throw out.
>> You know which one I'm talking about? So, in order to
get into it, you have to be verified. >> Boots on the ground
using the flimsiest of excuses to uh send military troops into
other American cities. That's not a line for you. He's talking
about Chicago. He's talking about Philadelphia. talking about
he's talking about specifically Chicago is next on the list.
He already did Los Angeles, right? Um so >> it depends.
It depends what it's for. If he does with LA where the there's
federal uh troops because that's what they were >> uh federal
troops that were there to >> I don't have uh I don't have
Streamyard set up. I just want their job federally. >> You're
saying they did nothing but
you're right. Yeah. If if you're telling me is my line if they
send feds that do
>> That's not a line for me. They do something really bad
then that could be a line. >> Okay. All right. Well, I
I'll leave that there. I won't make this whole thing about that.
Alexander win for $10. Um, Corey, don't you know anytime it's
convenient, it's fact. Um, inconvenient rigged. Um, >> I
just threw this calling by my name, though, just FYI. >> We
do. It's a C. Uh, there like like right there. Um, Dub, sorry,
you went to say something to Lost and he's back. >> Oh,
no. Yes. So, I posted more. >> Yeah. Okay. So, I posted
more and there there's more, right? >> Okay. Is this in
Discord? >> Uh, I it's in the group. Yeah. So, there there's
a lot more. Um, and so the last one I just posted is uh so I'm
trying to verify this, right? I don't want to say actually I
just want to say I'm not sure if it's true, right? But, um, so
I'll clear that up after I like have to look into it. So, but
I think that's enough evidence that yeah, he has been involved
in the doxing. Uh Dan's been involved in boxing. Uh this Niko
Sam guy seems like uh like legitimate, right? What he said in
that guy said in the email, >> I think I don't know if
I've said this, but um Nico Sam came to me with the exact things
he put on uh like I it's like basically public information. NicoSam
went on KF and said that Dan came to him with the Twitter account
that docks President Sunday and that he he basically believes
that Dan was involved in doxing President Sunday. Nikosam came
with that to me. I said I'm not going to publish it because I
don't want to publish this. Right? I'm not I'm not a publisher.
Don't come to me to publish stuff. Okay? You make a public statement,
I'll cover it. But if you don't want to make a public statement,
then I like I don't know what to do, right? And I I don't think
he wanted to do it that way. So I I passed, but I he brought
this to me I want to say in like like January, February of this
year. Um so I' I've kind of known about that, but realistically
like there's not a lot of proof there. It's just him being in
those servers and then saying, "Yes, like uh like I was given
this this Twitter account by Dan or I was told to look at this
Twitter account by Dan." And there's something about like the
language is the same as the language Destiny uses when he goes
to docs when he goes to doc Sunday in his DG chat, which he did
by the way. Um yeah, there's some other stuff there. So, I have
like some
like side proof that the Nikico Sam like I I know that that's
Niko Sam who thinks that, right? where I'm 99% sure that it's
Nikico Sam who who was saying that. Um he gave me like a whole
document but I I like I said just publishing it seemed weird
when it did when it was light on evidence. It was just his like
innuendo, but this came out of like the server where >> on
the like the 22nd I think or like it was like three or four three
or five three or four days before Destiny said on stream that
they were trying to find this girl, right? >> Yeah, I can
see all that. >> Yeah, all that seems to match up to me,
right? So this and this is why I think yeah, he's been involved
with this kind of stuff and I can't find anything.
>> Well, okay. Sorry, I keep doing my hand thing. Um, yeah,
I understand that at this juncture like the burden is on me.
Oh, just real quick as well, I should rehighlight that Niku Sam
gave all this stuff up, that he wants to be left alone, that
he is not involved in any of this stuff. Just he was involved.
Uh he saw the error of his ways. He's no longer involved. Okay,
leave Niku Sam alone. Leave Nico alone to show that this is a
countdock and not just a first strike, if you will. So, I do
understand that and I apologize. I don't use Discord on my computer
very often and it's updating and I'm on my phone on the uh this
stupid app streamard thing and so every time I like downsize
the window it it kicks me out. So just bear with me and I'll
uh I'll be on tomorrow too if you want to chat it up. >> Sure.
Yeah, of course. >> Yeah. I don't know I don't know if
if if that like meets your standard, right? Um but this is just
the first thing that like I could find um which is um from the
Triple 9 Society, right? So they require either Stanford Renee
or the um Wesler. Yeah, there's there's like so much better content
going on. I'm just
so I have to go. >> Uh, thank you uh DBY. Um, thank you
Alexander $5 saying I'll never spend Cory's name. >> Yo,
I just wanted to say I appreciate the discourse. Still love you,
bud.
>> He was just saying he likes you. You're
>> like
social progressive like social like you know like a >> one
of the things does take courage to come and defend your position.
I think more people should do it as opposed to just anonymously
trash talkinging in the chat. Uh, and you should look into >> He
didn't defend his positions at all. His positions are completely
indefensible. He had no evidence for them. He is totally brainwashed,
right? Like this is just embarrassing. Don't say, "Oh, you did
a good job coming on when he's a totally brainwashed."
That's embarrassing for you, too. Oh, well, I'm glad you came
on to like embarrass yourself here in front of everybody and
show up and make strong assertions and have absolutely no proof
for them whatsoever.
It's It's so goofy, dude. He Yes, he absolutely gloated. He was,
"Oh, I'm going to post evidence before Dubie." And then he types
a whole bunch. He goes AFK for like 15 minutes and comes back
and goes, "Guys, this is really complicated. I can't post. I
don't know. I don't know, man. This is really complicated." And
you could see even his argument on on some of the Rose stuff
is like, "Would Destiny Destiny's a smart guy. Would he really
do that?" Yes. Yes. He's a Yes. He's a on this topic.
Would Destiny really just lie? Would Destiny really just like
make a horrible decision? Would he really just like out himself
for retaining Cam? Would he really do that? Yes. Yes, he would.
do the psychological profile of online trolls. Not so great.
>> Oh, Cory, how do you how do you you've been on this
panel for years and you're always so pleasant. I don't understand
how you maintained this uh decorum for >> I also score
high on sociopathy. So,
>> Palestine Prime, thanks for having me, boys. It's >> okay.
All right. Well, that was a panel. That was a panel that existed.
That was a thing. Let's uh let's check out Let's see here. Uh
the person who updates Destiny's sheet is uh maybe they're turning
anti. The person who usually gives the time stamps for Destiny's
stream didn't do that today for some reason. So now I have to
go scan this on my own, which is [__] up. All right,
let me go see where we get to Ethan stuff here. Son scanning
for an Ethan time stamp. I could just try to go to O, but I don't
really want to just go do O. There's some Ethan right here. Okay,
on to the Ethan stuff, guys. Let's see what >> Destiny
update video.
>> Which does anyone care? Like, bro, you >> Hey,
Lawson did literally exactly what I told you the other DJs do
when you ask for evidence. I beg them for something, anything,
and promise to change my tune if it's concrete enough. And they
just say he's formed a hate community. That's literally it. Yeah,
I know. But, but the sad thing is is like
I This is how you know that it's like cultish, right? Is when
they don't feel embarrassed about that. When they will go back
to make that argument again. They'll say they could prove it
and then they embarrass themselves again. They'll just embarrass
themselves again and embarrass themselves again and embarrass
themselves again. That's like the cultlike thing where that I've
noticed. And it's just like I can't really like handle it anymore.
It was It was like funny for a little bit to bring them on and
humiliate them and make them like look really stupid and and
like I I have a hard time doing it, you know, more than once
now. There was a time period where I could do it like endlessly
and now it's just like, okay, this is like this is like what
they actually want. They're like getting off to it. This is what
they want. >> Does anyone care? Oh, they're Oh, they're
so happy. Oh my god.
All the guys in the chairs finally have somebody that they can
laugh with Ethan about again because they've been too much of
a spineless coward to say anything about their actual come source
Hassan for the past year while Ethan's been [__]
source. He's doing it again. He's talking about He's talking
about it again. Take a everybody take a there's there's a come
reference. Godamn going on stream. Oh, how cute. I'm so happy
that they all bond over >> you. You click anywhere on this
VOD and you're like 30 seconds away from a come >> I will
be your shared enemy that you hate. That's fine. I hope that
um raid DJers don't hack their accounts again like uh what was
it? That's that Stariller, the AB guy when he was caught posting
in a snark um in the Snark subreddit and then he was like I think
it was actually >> dude actually.
What the [__] I've never even Google who [__]
this guy was. What? I still don't even know how the crow on the
show. I only know this guy's Dan because I have a Dan and they're
both called
I don't even know who these people are. I Who is this guy? Who's
this guy? I've only watched like hours and hours and hours of
their content. I've totally know who he is. I totally talked
about how he saves Ethan. I've totally made actual statements
about him as a person before. But now, because I'm mad at them,
I'm going to pretend I don't know this guy. Cool. Very cool.
How that's like that has to be peak narcissism, right? Where
the biggest insult you can do to somebody is saying you don't
know who they are. That's got to be what peak narcissism is.
I don't even know who this guy is. Who even is this guy? Who
even are these people? It's like that's the best thing you could
give to them is the the recognition that you know them. Dan
>> like arguing the semantics of like actually it's called
a heopile. It means I just want to [__] teenagers,
not not >> Who's even arguing any of this? You called me
a and now you're saying that if you 19year-old it's the same
thing. There's a >> I just think it's funny to have the
matching title to go with the entire look, right? Personally,
like now I have plausible deniability to call him a because he
minor or sorry, tried to [__] minor, right? So I
have the plausible deniability to say it now, you know, by internet
rules. But if you push me, I'll say dictionary wise, no, it's
primary attraction to to previous kids, and I don't believe Destiny
has that, right? But now I can match like the the facial look,
the overall look that he has to the title. And that's just exciting.
Okay. It's like match. It's like, dude, it's like um Oh, it's
like playing what what's the memory game. You know the memory
game where you pick the pairs, right? It's like finding the first
pair there. You've like done a couple concentration. Is that
what it's called? It's like I see the picture and I get the word
turned over and I'm like, "Yes."
Oh, it just feels good to connect them finally.
Being a kids. Okay. Something that your country Israel is tough
>> notoriously known for giving cover for pro Palestine.
I need an Arabic a shahid or raid or whatever it's called song
button on my soundboard. Okay.
>> Like is that really the conversation we're going to
be having here with
>> Who is having the comment? Just don't accuse me of that
you have no idea about. That's how hard is that? How >> Destiny,
did you or did you not retain CSAM? Destiny, did you or did you
not retain CSAM? This is another thing that Ethan does. Unfortunately,
when Ethan knows that Destiny's going to react, he should just
say, "Destiny, the question you won't answer is, did you or did
you not retain CSAM?" Destiny, did you or did you not? If that
girl is 17, did you or did you not retain CSAM? Hard is
>> Um, like I like unfortunately that's really the question
that you would want to ask, right? Did you retain job? Did you
retain job? Did you retain job without alerting the authorities?
Did your Did your lawyers I want I want actually this on the
record, too. Did your lawyers advise you to retain child because
that child would be consequential in your civil case? Didn't
you didn't you say that? Because that's the counter-argument
to that, by the way, that oh, he needs it for a civil case. No,
he doesn't. It literally can't be evidence in a civil case. It
can't be evidence. The civil case is not a child thing. The CSAM
itself cannot be evidence in that case.
He's always like, why do we even have to talk about it? Why don't
even like, bro, you're the one who's reading down my Kiwi Farms
thread on your show. Oh, what the >> actually I didn't
have 60 gigs of of child only only one picture. I actually only
had one video of child. >> We're going to get a no response
to that >> You know this. >> Save it for the video.
>> I don't respond to that one or
>> notice how he lets that one go. That one. Every other
one he's really really really fast to jump in and go stop making
things up Ethan. You're making things up. And then Ethan says
that he's like what? Like who's forcing you? Who's the person
who is forcing this guy to make videos about me? There's got
to be like some super.
>> It just didn't answer the question at all. He just let
it go by, right? I have zero bites of cesam is something he could
have said. He could have said
>> What? Good guy. >> Only one picture. >> I
actually only had one video of child. I'm actually I don't know
if you know >> Save it for the video. >> I don't
feel like making it [__] >> Okay, good. What?
Who's for
I don't feel like making it cuz it's so dumb. You the person
who is forcing this guy to make videos about me. There's got
to be like some super
of all the people behind the scenes and I just need to get connected
to that guy. Like who's controlling Hassan? Who's controlling
Ethan? Who's controlling everybody to hate me? It's a deep state
conspiracy.
My uh my ears are burning, guys. My ears are burning.
Oh boy. My ears are burning right now. He doesn't know. He doesn't
know. He doesn't know. >> Bring up his Boston bombing vid.
Why? What happened? Did he >> Dude, imagine being the most
unlikable
seam retaining adjacent person on planet Earth. Okay. And all
you can say is exasperated is sigh. All you can do is sigh with
exasperation. Go. Why do all these people not like me? Why doesn't
anybody like me? All these people are so weird that they don't
like me. No, it's like the most natural thing in the world, actually.
You're like an awful human being. You You flaunt that
At least, dude, the reason people kind of liked you before is
cuz you look like a smart person, too. You're awful, but at least
you're smart. Kind of like House. Now you look like a like a
malicious evil. Like, you've lost the last redeeming quality
you had. People are like, "He's so smart that he might save democracy
even though he's an awful person." No, now you just look like
a [__] idiot, too.
You've lost like you've lost the one thing that redeemed you
in like some people's minds was you, oh, you're smart and you
could help save democracy. No, that's not happening. Also,
yeah, history alert. Ethan is the product of a ebopile relationship.
Okay, cuz his dad was 21 and his mom was 16 when they >> You
were 33 and she was 17. You were 33 and she was 17. You were
33 and she was 17. You were 33 and she was 17. It's much weirder.
It's much weirder. It's much much much weirder. Okay.
I dude >> name it. That's confirmed.
>> The same.
>> I'm happy to go home. >> I know Willie Mack is
making an update. Did he post? I don't know.
>> Check it out. He's going to lay it all >> Destiny
was my roommate. I get him late all the time. >> That Z
trick is still working with him.
>> I'm just looking forward to now. Like the thing we look
forward to now, I assume, is um the people in these group chats
or people close to Destiny turning on him as well, right? Like
Willie Mack was the first one that realized, oh [__]
we got to get out. But who's the next one? Who's the next one?
He shared some videos with what he was looking for all where
he's looking for Rose or whatever the [__] been going
on, right? Who's the next one to turn? He's he's doing all these
jokes. He's doing a lot of memeing, but in the back of his head,
he's got to be thinking like, who's the next one, right? Who's
left? Well, I'm just saying that like I haven't heard Ardite
speak. I haven't really heard Dan make a statement like are one
of these people going to come out and go you know what we actually
have to we actually have to abandon ship we got to show we got
to show that Darius has left. Ooh I've heard I've heard Darius
had a bunch of stuff right? I've heard Darius had a whole bunch
of stuff. What about Lerbox? Lerbox is not on Destiny's side
like it not in a tangible like I understand that Lonerbox is
just like a show me the evidence kind of guy. All right like
I need to see all the evidence or
There's probably more than that. I I don't want to talk about
her box. Computer isn't working. I'm sure she'll come out against
him soon. I We'll see. We'll see. >> Um actually, this
text message was with somebody else. I've only spoke inappropriately
with other teenagers three or four times. Not this one in >> That
person was in there twy
he's freaking out cuz Ethan showed those other texts. Did Ethan
not go through and just show like what was real and what wasn't?
Did he not like follow up today or because yeah, showing those
texts and saying they were from Rose is probably pretty bad,
but why not just go through the actual text from Rose if you're
going to do that? >> Incredibly weird and creepy. If he
thought Just think about how weird and creepy it is if he thought
that these were child texts back and forth. Why the is he reading
it off on
um if that was actually me?
Why are you like mad about it and and reading them off? Why why
would you read Why would you read those off? Um that's like really
bad. That's really bad of you. Why not? The argument would be
that it's a it's a you know semi not semi-even. It's like act
involving a minor and so even with those you should refrain.
I've kind of like let it go when it's um on other people's stuff
or when it's like you know evidence for a point. I've not gone
through and read it all. I I don't know if I could like I don't
know if I could really justify going through and reading them
all. Right. Text can't be seam. I'm aware text can't be seam.
It's still like um it's still like it's bordering on something
that's weird. Right. That counts as cam. I don't think it counts
as seam. Well, sorry. I don't think it counts as like child of
the law. I don't think like those texts would be um I don't think
there's an argument that those texts would would count the same
way as like actual child. Reading Vos DMs recently got some people's
YT hit. Yeah, it would. Unironically, next Jer needs to provide
an outline to Ethan for him to make a video. It's too much lore.
Uh, Ethan can pay researchers. Ethan has more than enough money.
If he could pay to sue Caseyron, he can pay researchers to make
his anti-destiny video. Okay? He could not be a lazy loser. Okay?
Or if he's going to be a lazy loser, pay some people. You're
rich as stream. Are you crazy? Like, if you legitimately think
that these are inappropriate conversation between an adult and
a minor, why are you gooning to the material on your stream?
That's so weird. What the There's something particularly disconcerting
about a person who did have a relationship um like a relationship
with a minor going drawing attention to this by reading off what
I said is actually really gross on your part. Okay. Like referencing
the fact that Destiny and this minor were discussing a a shared
going twinsies on butt plugs like that is apparently offensive
to Destiny in a way that retaining the CSAM was not right. in
a way in a way that leaking all of his private relationship texts
with Lauren Southern to this 19-year-old he'd only known for
like 3 months was not sorry purported 19-year-old purported 18-year-old
whatever age he thought she was right he knew she was like either
freshly 18 or like somewhere between you know 17 and 19 okay
and he shared all of his romantic romantic messages with somebody
who's apparently the love of his life with that teenager who
he'd only known for like 3 months I don't know that to me is
like another one of those things I realize
assuming assuming he thinks she's an adult or like 18, right?
That might be one of the more disgusting things in there to be
honest with you. Like you think that's your soulmate and you're
going to you're going to share all of your extremely personal
private texts for your like trying to save the relationship with
a minor sex worker that you've known well sorry with a sex worker
that you've known for 3 months. Shouldn't include the minor part.
He might not have known it. That's that's wild to me. That's
crazy. Bro, you're you're a creep. You're a deviant creep with
a clear persistent pattern of trying to flirt with with fantasize
a pattern. All of my major dramas are with older women even.
How old was Lav or was Lav 15? I don't know. Maybe everybody
pattern of being an abusive piece of [__] Um I don't
think he's a pattern of what is it? Like a pattern of targeting
children? Yeah, I don't think so. Really, if anything, we could
say he's a pattern of ignoring children, right? like a pattern
of targeting children. No, it's like the opposite pattern of
being a total piece of [__] also. Yes. Lies by their
birthday. Annavoir was my age, right? Like minus 2 years. Was
she lying about her age? What are all of these? What the dude?
This whole cadence is like so unbelievable to me now. Uh I occasionally
see names that I'm just like this Wicked Demier guy who's actually
really smart. It's like really depressing that he is uh like
a full-on cult member. That's sad. >> It's about minors.
Just admit that that you're that's and people defending Destiny.
Just admit that that you're cool with that. >> You can
keep watching Destiny. You can keep being a fan. But we don't
need to argue the semantics, you know, of it. Just just admit
that he's a creep and that he wants to [__] teenagers.
>> If you want to call me a creep, okay, then fine. I don't
give a call a creep. I don't give a Why would I care? Okay, you
can't even make it through four.
child connoisseur is probably what I go with. I think child connoisseur
is like a
punchy gets the point across. Factually correct. Okay. Child
afficionado. Something along these lines. Something like this
would be better. Don't call him a creep cuz that kind of minimizes,
right? He's like a child dragon. He's like sits on a horde of
child. I'm not totally sure. We could find it. We we'll find
it. There's a there's there's a word for it. Words without I'm
sorry. No, I'm not sorry for this guy. If you don't call me creep,
that's fine. But there's a huge difference between creep versus
predator. Like you have to understand there's a big difference
between these two things. All right.
>> Not like weird not like weird like almost like like
they've gone through puberty teenagers. >> I I would love
if somebody asked Destiny why he thought he would be done if
she was a minor cuz it seems like something's changed there.
Why did he in his own opinion think that he would be done if
she was a minor? That he'd be cooked. Is it almost like he understands
exactly why that line's there and why that line is so bad when
creators cross >> 161 17. He just wants to [__]
16 17 year olds. It's not pett. >> What the [__]
What? >> Um, technically it's only >> Wait, where
are all of these other girls and people coming from? 15year-old,
16 year olds? What What are we talking about? Does he have like
a fanfiction?
>> I just wonder when he started texting Molina. How old
was Molina when you guys started texting? Like this does happen.
Um, I don't think he has like a primary sexual attraction to
little girls or something, but I I mean some kind of like a violating
social convention maybe.
In any case, uh yeah, this this
we're just starting to see that like this guy was a total piece
of [__] before this. Uh it is it is funny and it's
it's funny that what might get him his comeuppance is his hoarding
of the Cam, like the actual child. But it does come down to ultimately
it's why Ryan Beard's first video is the best takedown of Destiny,
right? because it shows the pattern of behavior, how he's just
a totally like he's totally psychotic to anybody who threatens
like his community's view of him. If anybody is like basically
promoting a message that he is a bad person, his community is
at all bought into it, that person has to be destroyed mercilessly.
That's like kind of the more perpetual pattern over time that
he's writing in his mind of >> Pedophilia, if they haven't
hit puberty, >> I would say yes. Hold on. That jiggle girl
was 16. I don't know how old she was cuz she says she's 16. I
don't totally know. But um what I would say is I don't think
he is at all morally opposed to
girl who is like in that age range if he could get away with
it. Right. Seems like that's pretty clear like he's made that
clear over time. So whatever that is wouldn't say it's a primary
attraction but whatever the that is right. >> I actually
want to [__] women or I actually want to [__]
little girls who have hit puberty but are still under the age
of consent. That's my preference. >> I would have more
respect for the defenders if they were just like yeah I'm cool
with it. >> Okay. Someone said Ethan you shouldn't exaggerate
the destiny of claims. Okay. Well, yeah, of course, but that's
because you support 9-year-olds getting, right? Isn't he Muslim
or whatever? So, your opinion is obviously not very relevant
here. Thank you. >> You shouldn't exaggerate the destiny
of claims. Okay, so I'm making this video. >> Old and horrifying
video of H3H. I don't want to do this. Do I care? >> Hey
guys, here. Watch your hands cuz you you're going to get cut
up on this one here, guys. You can scar me. This >> I'm
going to go back to A and just see if I've got any other clips
here. Watching this guy kind of makes me ill. He said that once.
Wait, he said what
Oh, that he just doesn't care. I mean, he said it more than once
that he just doesn't care or professed it at least
So, more than once. Let me see here. Let me see if there's anything
else in this back and forth. Ethan not has no idea about takes
at Israel and Ethan's parents. There was a lowb blow at AB. I
think that's just it. See what we got for comments here. All
these people to hate me. Yes, this was the funny part. Okay.
Who's controlling all these people to hate me? I only needed
one reason to Destiny. Just one. But ever since you celebrated
the death of Cory Comparator, I've been given so many more reasons
to utterly despise you. Yeah, he really needs to shut up if he
wants to come out of his the investigations lawsuits without
going to jail. Isosu is a 19-year-old child. She was not 19.
I think we all have a pretty good idea of what it's about. The
docs, the [__] himself just to hit just to get hit
with the hard truth. He's a kitty freak. Sucks to suck. O replies,
"Man, I thought there was going to be something
sick here, but this is not the evil Stark behavior that Ethan
is falling for." What? Okay. All right. Um,
are we going to I think we close off with the Aiden stuff tonight.
Is that where we're going? End of the stream. We're going to
close up with the Aiden stuff. What else do we got here? Just
making sure I don't Didn't forget anything. Am I pulling up that
Aiden stream? I've got the AB and Preach video. Is there anybody
who's not who's been waiting? Okay. Hasn't posted the AB and
Preach video. Oh, this is the other thing. Kathy, so nice of
you to join us, Kathy. Apparently, so I didn't go watch the whole
H3 episode. There's this part as well.
The clip that O doesn't want us to see. Hold on. Destiny CPS.
Oh. >> Oh, my good friend. >> Lots of on Ian for
being a total dope idiot weirdo. Uh, lots of Destiny followup,
which we're in a VOD. That would that means a VOD on demand will
be after this episode ends to be brought to you postp. >> Oh,
wait. They're going to do another one. Wait, is that out yet?
That might >> for enjoying the VODs. Everybody's, you know,
people are turning around on the VODs. They are saying, "We love
VODs. They're doing wonderful things with the >> The VODs
are, you know, the best VODs." Lots of >> I hope CPS takes
his kids. I'll say it. I do. And I hope they cry about it. And
then CPS come for my kid. And then CPS can take Dan's kids. You
know what? All of our children at the end of the day will just
be fostered by Child Protective Services. Okay? And that'll just
be And then we can all relieve ourselves. It's He's just going
to be a rehash of all the every other video made. God, it's so
crazy how this >> I don't particularly care about the uh
the CPS comment. It is ironic coming from him given his situation.
It's ironic.
Um dude, this guy is just like playing all sides of everything
right now, right? He just doesn't actually believe in anything.
And then they can take dance kids, too. I'm going to just keep
making it absurd now. Now that I said I'm just going to keep
making it absurd, more and more absurd. And oh, and also, is
this going to be the same as every other video? Probably not.
I don't think I don't think most of the videos out about Destiny
right now are talking about his uh his doxing of the girl to
his Kiwi Farms thread like his him providing PII to find her
and basically himself in the foot here. Okay. I don't think there's
I haven't seen a punchy video about it yet. There's not a single
video that is punchy and shows that he provided the information
that led to people realizing he'd been storing Cessam on his
computer. I mean, Wait, did you see the low blow that Destiny
took at AB?
Oh, the what the
is this different? So, I saw the the a clip for a second, but
is this different than the
what was it that you're a Muslim
>> I actually want to
have hit puberty but are still under the age of 9year-olds. >> That's
my >> I would have more respect for the defenders if they
were just like, "Yeah, I'm cool with it." >> Okay. Someone
said, "Ethan, you shouldn't exaggerate the destiny of claims."
Okay. >> Well, yeah, of course, but that's because you
support 9year-olds getting right. Isn't he Muslim or whatever?
So, your opinion is obviously not very relevant here. Thank you.
>> You shouldn't exaggerate the destiny of claims. Okay.
You guys want me? >> Okay, this is the Tree of Logic clip
we had on stream. So, box, I I ser I swear to God if I click
on this and it doesn't work, I am uh I I'm telling you right
now, I will swear off kick clips for like until it's fixed. If
this breaks, I'm going to lose it. >> Any [__]
goddamn pooky who goes after little girls who >> Oh, we
watched this on stream already, but we'll watch it again. >> [__]
age is a goddamn piece of [__]
Clip that. Get mad at that. >> Oh, Wes. Yeah, I'm I'm looking
forward to watching the Streamhouse. Is Wes doing it or is it
just all in Sam's stream? Where where is it getting done? Where
can I find the clips cuz I saw that as well? Okay. Anyway, we
we aren't done by Child Protective Services. Okay. And that'll
just be and then we can all relieve ourselves. He's just going
to be a rehash of all the every other video made. God, it's so
crazy how this
um as he's spamming on Instagram and coughing and dying of whatever
diseases he has. >> Destiny was totally psyched when Ethan
would do the same thing to Hassan, by the way. Destiny loved
it. Destiny absolutely loved it. >> Is is telling me like,
"Oh, Destiny, I used to like you so much and you need help and
blah blah blah." It's like the the exact the exact Assad was
doing to
Good memes. Oh, wow. Oh boy. All of these guys are like pointing
fingers. It's just Spider-Man pointing at Spider-Man pointing
at Spider-Man pointing at a Okay. Like all these people are terrible.
They do lie about each other because they've gotten past the
point where they care to validate any story about one another,
right? Just one of them retained several cam videos, right? Multiple
CSAM videos. Unfortunately, that puts him lower than the rest
of the like totally amoral to our massive streamers.
Okay.
Unlucky. Unlucky. Unlucky. I dislike Destiny, but what happened?
Innocent till proven guilty. Why are we calling him a before
solid evidence? I don't know. It's just weird to me. Um, trip
to pound town. He literally
said he retained the videos of Rose. We know that the videos
of Rose were when she was 17 or younger because time works linearly.
So, he has retained a bunch of CSAM for months without alerting
the authorities. We're calling him a because he's holding child.
Is that technically the definition of No, but it is enough for
most people.
If you hold, you know, gigabytes and gigabytes of child, people
will call you a
breaks, buddy. Do you need any proof of that? Cuz I'm perfectly
happy to walk through it with you. Or is that just some random
concern trolling and we're going to run away now? Cuz that's
basically the argument you have to make that I don't believe
this guy is a We have not seen the evidence though. It's all
hearsay. No, Destiny's direct testimony is this. This is Destiny's
direct testimony. Destiny has said this directly. Destiny received
multiple videos. He has retained all files received from Rose.
What do you think that means? Destiny has taken videos received
from Rose and sent stills from those videos to a group chat trying
to find Rose. How did he do that without retaining CSAM? This
is proven. This is not an allegation. This there is full-on evidence
to show this. There's Destiny's own testimony, his own recollection,
his own statement of fact being the strongest piece of evidence.
Oh my god. What's the evidence that she's 17? I'll I'll give
you the tweet of a man with at least 30 IQ points on you, Draciel.
Hold on. Hold on. Hold on. Tom Foolery P. Let me go find the
Tom Fooly thing. I'll put that in the I'll put that in the chat
for you. Tom harvesting W's now. Okay. Tom's just harvesting
W's. That's crazy. at Draciel
right there, buddy. Right there. Tom explains it. You just go
read Tom's post. Uh yeah, go check it out. Did the trip to pound
town guy just not want to? Desty said she was 17. Oh, we have
all of the evidence in the world. She was 17, right? Well, let's
read it. Let's read it just so you guys can actually read it
with us just one more time because it is it is important. Okay.
I don't know how many people have done this, but I did verify
that Rose was under 18 in 2022. I keep saying or I keep seeing
people say it's unverified. So, in case you didn't know, I figured
I'd explain it here. There's a photo of her in DG merch from
a Discord server. Uh, it's not just from a Discord server. Destiny
posted it in DGG chat saying it was Rose and doxing Rose's college,
the girl's college, right? And her face to Kiwi Farms while taunting
Kiwi Farms and saying you can't find her, right? So, okay. So,
that's the first piece of evidence is Desty says this is Rose.
Desty gave a picture of her face and her college. Okay, so this
is the same girl in the that photo. The same girl in that photo
is the same person in the news interview, the news interview
at the beginning of the Willy video. The name on the news interview
is the same as the name on the speeding ticket as is the city.
So the city is the same. The name is the same. The speeding ticket
has her birthday, her birth month. That makes her 17 at the time,
turning 18 on October. Most state websites don't put two-digit
years, but I've confirmed that this one does by looking up more
names and found 87,71, 92, etc. So, showing that they have to
be uh what do you call it? Like years instead of months or dates.
Okay. I've searched her name in other places to see the same
name, face, and birth date all match other websites. Right. Destiny
also said in DG chat in May what college Rose went to. That the
same individual went to that same school. So, if you don't trust
people who have claimed to verify it so far, add me to the list.
Not making any claims about anyone knowing or when they knew
only that she was 17 until October of 2022. I told my audience
days ago that it was confirmed, but I figured I'd put it here,
too. Uh, Dracul, yes, the site literally has a tick mark for
juveniles. She is not a juvenile any longer, so her profile no
longer shows her as juveniles. U, there's also public record
of both her and her mother being served as a part of a hit and
run that happened, right? Both her and her mom were served. That
only apparently happens if she's a juvenile. But regardless,
it shows that um that this is the same person and that the birth
date is correct. Like you're literally arguing with government
systems that are accurate for everybody. Yes, it was a it was
a traffic citation. Trip to pound. Destiny himself has said he
is in possession of it. Destiny himself has produced artifacts
of it and said that they are artifacts of the videos. Trip to
pound. Do you understand that Destiny himself says, "Yes, I do
have this video of Rose having said, "Yes, here is a screen of
this video showing the title of the video with Rose having said
that is something Destiny has said. Do you understand?" I I shouldn't
be shocked because we've watched Destiny admit things before
over Discord messages, right? I violated her privacy in the most
egregious way possible and many people will argue that that was
not a confession of guilt, right? Many sorry, totally brain will
argue that that's not a confession of guilt. So that live that
ticket is a live document that updates with her age. No. When
you look up her profile on the website, that is a live profile
that updates with her age as in when she's no longer a juvenile.
Apparently doesn't take juvenile anymore. So she is no longer
a juvenile,
right? She was a juvenile in 2022. So the ticket is a part of
her profile. The profile updates over time. The ticket would
be an immutable artifact. Are you still confused? Um there's
also So there's a new piece of evidence that came out recently.
Somebody sent it to me. I'll read this off. Give me a second.
Give me a second. Give me a second. So, I don't know if you've
heard. It's a new bit of evidence.
Car accident at 16 in 2021.
And there is a record of this.
Oh, there's a record of this. And not only that, but she was
sued for it. She was sued for it. And there's a Facebook post
of the person who was hit by the car, and they say, "A 16 year
old girl hit me today." Lines up totally with the time and the
age. There's a Facebook post of the person who got hit saying
they're in the hospital and I got [__] up by I got
hit by a 16-year-old girl today. So, she tried to So, this is
actually the same ticket. So, she actually got sued for this.
She was trying to run a red light. >> She got hit or sorry,
she hit this >> just tipped uh
>> How mad will the haters be when this drama blows over
and people still prefer even CP can do it? A real Mantis tweet
on X.
She was 16 in 2021 when she got into the accident. There is a
record of the civil litigation for the same person who makes
the Facebook post with the girl who is named because as if it's
a part of her juvenile record. Why is it released now? I Who
are you? Is this guy talking to somebody else? It's not a part
of a It's not not criminal. They're civil. They're civil records,
right? There's not a criminal action taking place. She didn't
get arrested or if she did get arrested, that's not public record.
That's not what we're looking at. I I really even more than um
even more than just talking about like the actual facts of the
matter. Dracula, don't you feel like weird
when everybody here can can look at this evidence? They can identify
it. Um lots of a ton of neutral people can look at this evidence,
identify it. Tom Foolery, who is a massive Destiny fan, who is
totally monetarily incentivized to continue supporting Destiny,
can look at this evidence and go, "Yeah, it's obvious that this
person was 17." Does that not concern you that you are sitting
here arguing against like bulletproof evidence like this? I would
just I I would personally feel a little concerned that I'm I'm
sitting there like not knowing stuff right from a place of ignorance
arguing that everybody else is wrong. That would feel concerning
to me. I understand it doesn't disturb you, but have you thought
about why that might be? Yeah, that's another fantastic point.
Albert, yes, Destiny doesn't seem to deny that she's likely 17.
Okay, we took that little bit of time. I don't believe the Ethan
video is out yet, guys. I would love to watch that Ethan video
if it were out, but it's not out yet. Probably have to be content
for tomorrow. Let's go to the Aiden Underground stream for a
quick second. All right,
>> So, if you guys don't remember yesterday, okay, Aiden
had
bit of controversy yesterday.
He went live. Purple Perry looked at his DMs. Purple Perry Gaming
went and looked through his DMs while Aiden walked away from
his computer. Leaked that Nicholas Yorio was apparently seething
about Queen in Aiden's DMs. Kind of goofy. Is this Dracula guy
still asking questions?